[Musique]
oui c'est bien ce mariage que nous
ouvrons au couple de même sexe 29
janvier 2013 Christiane Taubira alors
garde des sceaux défend le projet de loi
de mariage pour tous devant l'Assemblée
nationale
[Musique]
un projet de loi qui divise les Français
[Applaudissements]
pendant 6 mois la France voit défiler
les anti mariage pour tous opposaient
l'adoption par des couples homosexuels
prévus par cette loi
ce sont toujours les mêmes
revendications nous sommes pour la
défense de l'enfant et de la famille la
défense de l'enfant d'avoir un père et
une mère
à cette époque Cyril et Florian
n’étaient pas encore tombés amoureux
tous les deux se rappellent de cette
période comme si c'était hier longtemps
puisque
j'ai grandi comme tout le monde dans la
même société que tout le monde et en
fait j'ai jamais vu de différence
moi à celle de mes frères et sœurs autre
que le droit de se marier et le droit de
fonder sa propre famille tel qu'on
l'entend on avait l'impression qu'en
fait tout était permis les gens
pouvaient se permettre de dire n'importe
quoi de
d'avoir une certaine discret une
discrimination qui était très ouverte et
c'est vrai que pour le coup pour moi ça
j'ai beaucoup de colère j'ai eu de la
colère et ça m'a presque déclencher un
sentiment de revanche où je me suis dit
un jour je me marierai comme vous pour
331 contre
225 le 23 avril 2013 la loi est adoptée
par l'Assemblée nationale
le mariage et l'adoption sont ouverts à
tous Cyril et Florian peuvent enfin
prendre leur revanche
[Musique]
c'était vraiment par amour en fait on
s'est marié par amour
et important de se marier par amour oui
il m'a vraiment fait la demande parce
que parce qu'on était bien parce qu'on
est heureux parce que je les ai
comprendre aussi que on était heureux il
pouvait
[Musique]
juste vivre la même vie
plan-plan que tout le monde en gros on
veut juste on veut juste les mêmes
droits et les mêmes problèmes et puis
les et puis vivre nos vies comme on a
envie de l'entendre
une vie ordinaire qu'il n'imagine pas
sans enfant c'est dans la tête de Cyril
que n'est d'abord cette envie bien avant
de rencontrer Florian il se lance dans
un projet d'adoption
ah ça a été très difficile ça a été très
difficile parce que à ce moment-là
j'avais essayé la coparentalité une fois
deux fois imaginez trois fois
j'ai mis tous mes espoirs dans
l'adoption
l'adoption nationale où je vais
rapidement compris que c'était pas
possible l'adoption interne ou la
j'attendais et j'attends encore des
retours de mes de mes de mes demandes
là ça a été très compliqué où il a fallu
accepter que je peut-être je ne serai
pas parent car cyril est confronté à la
dure réalité des chiffres d'un côté la
France compte peu d'enfants à adopter
1000 pour 10000 agréments accordés
chaque année de l'autre le bilan 10 ans
après la loi environ 200 couples de même
sexe ont réussi à devenir parents par
cette voix depuis 2013
[Musique]
pour Tatiana Cordier juriste et
militante LGBT à Tours ce faible nombre
d'adoptions s'explique aussi par une
discrimination persistante
la loi pour le mariage pour tous a
permis au couple de penser que c'était
possible d'avoir accès à l'adoption
finalement les chiffres pourraient
montrer que c'est pas le cas et donc
c'est c'est assez énervant pour les
couples de se dire que on nous dit que
c'est possible on nous tend une carotte
et en fait dans les faits les conseils
départementaux et les conseillers
départementaux mettent les dossiers des
couples homoparentaux tout en dessous
des autres dossiers et en fait il passe
en dernier et non pas accès à ce bonheur
là d'être parents grâce à l'adoption
sur les six départements de la région
Centre-Val de Loire seul 3 nous ont
transmis les chiffres d'adoption par des
couples de même sexe
parmi eux le Loir-et-Cher en disant
trois couples ont pu adopter un enfant
moi je peux vous dire qu'aujourd'hui
dans la pratique aujourd'hui on a quand
même une pratique qui est extrêmement
claire on a des critères en fait
identifiés on instruit les dossiers où
on se base sur l'évaluation en fait des
travailleurs sociaux et l'évaluation des
psychologues et c'est sûr ces bases
d'argumentaires là que notre référent
adoption présente les dossiers et de
manière générale sur la présentation des
dossiers on nous suit là pas plus tard
qu'il y a quelques mois on a compris en
fait un enfant à un couple de même sexe
parce que c'était le projet le plus
cohérent au vu du profil de l'enfant et
du profil des personnes qui ont
candidaté l'idée c'est qu'il faut
s'engager de manière totale dans ce
futur projet d'adoption il y a certains
moments au cours en fait des évaluations
on peut avoir des couples qui
abandonnent en fait le projet parce que
finalement ils se rend compte qu'ils ne
sont pas prêts dans le projet ou
peut-être que ça arrivait trop tôt ou
que finalement c'était pas ce qu'ils
avaient envisagé comme comme procédure
donc on peut avoir ce genre de situation
là
les couples se détournent-ils de la
procédure d'adoption trop compliquée ou
sont-ils victimes d'une différence de
traitement toujours est-il que depuis
2022 une nouvelle loi prévoit la
présence d'un référent anti
discrimination dans les conseils de
famille
[Musique]
c'est lequel tu veux
après ça désillusion face à l'adoption
Cyril s'est relancé dans sa quête de
fonder une famille avec Florian cette
fois ils se sont tournés vers la
gestation pour autrui aux États-Unis
[Musique]
ils sont aujourd'hui les heureux parents
de Célia trois ans et demi
[Musique]
mais avant d'en arriver là un long
combat a été nécessaire
[Musique]
nous n'avions pas d'argent j'étais
salarié j'étais je gagnais 1200 euros
par mois mon mari 1100 euros et pas
d'économie pas de famille sur qui nous
pouvions compter et il a fallu trouver
cet argent on estimait à ce moment là
qu'il nous fallait à peu près 150 000
euros c'était une estimation
Cyril et Florian travaillent énormément
et obtiennent la confiance d'une banque
après plusieurs années de sacrifices ils
peuvent enfin financer leur parcours GPA
qu'ils ont voulu éthique
on s'est tout de suite orienté vers les
États-Unis puisqu'on savait que c'était
très organisé carré toutes les femmes ne
peuvent pas ne peuvent pas être
porteuses aux États-Unis il faut il y a
des règles il faut qu'elle travaille
qu'elles aient une situation et qu'elles
aient déjà leurs enfants ça nous a
vraiment permis de se rendre compte et
d'avoir une vraie gratitude en fait
envers ce qu'elle faisait on n'était pas
juste à louer son ventre voilà
vulgairement comme ce qui est dit on
était vraiment dans un échange et dans
une relation à prendre de ces nouvelles
régulièrement
elle nous en donnait aussi de de comment
elle allait de comment voilà quand elle
commençait à sentir le bébé qui bougeait
elle nous envoyait voilà des petits
messages ça y est je le sens boucher
à la naissance de Célia Florian et Cyril
sont tout de suite reconnus comme ses
parents aux États-Unis en France l'état
mettra trois ans à les reconnaître comme
tel
enfant elle a été elle a été plus que
plus que désiré
on est heureux en tant que parents on
est bien on est serein et puis on n'est
pas confronté à des problèmes plus
compliqués que d'autres parents donc on
est juste on est juste heureux d'être
parents
bon ça va aujourd'hui
nous retrouvons Tatiana Cordier et sa
femme Clémence chez elle près d'Amboise
elles se sont mariées dans un but très
précis l'accès à la procréation
médicalement assistée
mais on a décidé de se marier
principalement parce que la loi PMA
n'était pas encore passée on avait un
fort désir de fonder notre famille et
d'avoir un ou plusieurs enfants et on
est juriste toutes les deux et on
voulait se sécuriser et sécuriser nos
futurs enfants et c'était principalement
pour cette raison là qu'on s'est marié
et aussi un côté militant de se dire on
peut le faire donc on va le faire aussi
le fait que ça soit une obligation pour
enfin peut-être une obligation pour
avoir des enfants c'est quelque chose
qui me dérangeait un peu ça me
questionnait sur ma vraie volonté de me
marier est-ce que voilà est-ce que je le
fais pour quelle raison et puis et puis
après c'est vrai que c'est ce qu'on
s'est dit toutes les deux c'est le la
sécurité pour pour prendre notre famille
était plus importante que tout on s'aime
ça a été à mon gros moment d'amour donc
quoi qu'il arrive on regrette pas
depuis trois ans clémence et Tatiana
vivent au rythme de la PMA d'abord en
Belgique et désormais en France grâce à
la nouvelle loi bioéthique qui l'a
ouverte à toutes les femmes en 2021
qui
qui est prenant que ça soit physiquement
avec à l'époque Tatiana qui faisait les
piqûres et piqûres d'hormones ça
change ça change des choses ça change
notre quotidien les projets
le parcours en Belgique était payant
donc on a on a financé tout notre
parcours pendant deux ans ce qui
supposait ne plus faire autre chose à
côté maintenant on a juste à faire
quelques kilomètres pour aller faire nos
rendez-vous et on peut retourner au
travail le matin ou l'après-midi si on
le souhaite et on a un meilleur
accompagnement c'est moins fatigant
c'est pris en charge par la Sécurité
Sociale ça change énormément de choses
après il y a encore des inconvénients il
y a encore des limites à ce parcours là
mais c'est vrai qu'on a ayant vécu
l'avant à l'avant loi et le parcours à
l'étranger
c'est assez confortable à l'heure
actuelle pour nous de faire ce parcours
en ce moment mais le parcours PMA reste
une épreuve pour Tatiana et Clémence
entre les injections et les
inséminations forcément espacées de 6
mois tomber enceinte peut prendre
plusieurs années
une des limites de la PMA pour toutes
c'est le don de sperme le séquence
service médical d'aide à la fertilité du
centre hospitalier de Tours à multiplié
par 10 le nombre d'insémination depuis
la nouvelle loi bioéthique plus de la
moitié des patientes qu'on voit
actuellement en consultation ce sont des
couples de femmes et des femmes non
mariées ça représente la majorité des
consultations et donc on voit un petit
peu moins de couples hétérosexuels
aujourd'hui il y a eu vraiment un gros
afflux de demande de la part de ses
patientes en parallèle le nombre de dons
de sperme n'augmente pas et avec la
levée de l'anonymat prévu par cette loi
la situation risque de s'aggraver
tout ce qui est un peu inquiétant pour
l'avenir c'est qu'actuellement dans une
période un petit peu transitoire en
fonction encore avec la banque de
donneurs anonymes mais on sait qu'à très
court terme probablement un an un an et
demi on va nous demander de ne plus
utiliser cette banque de donneur qui ne
sont pas en accord avec ce nouveau texte
de loi et de basculer sur le nouveau
système donc il faut que dans le temps
très court on arrive à constituer une
nouvelle banque et c'est ce délai très
court qui fait qu'on a besoin
actuellement d'un afflux très important
de candidats aux dons
c'est à la PMA et à la parentalité
mariage reconnaissant ses protections
des enfants la loi de 2013 a marqué un
tournant essentiel dans la conquête des
droits de la communauté LGBT
[Musique]